Ukraine feeds the world
the words of this Farm's owner Victor
sherimeta gives us a tour on a cold
March morning on the outskirts of Kiev
corn wheat barley and where Ukraine
holds Pole Position globally sunflower
seeds the grain deal between Russia and
Ukraine brokered last July by the United
Nations and turkey is set to expire on
Saturday and there is a lot at stake
both at home and abroad
the grain deal gave us hope because our
internal prices dropped almost threefold
during the war but after it was signed
Prices rose and of course not like
before the war but they increased and
this gave us hope that we can work and
sell our harvest in the future
despite this
is a country at War
and what happens in these fields has
Global implications
Ukraine is one of the world's largest
producers of sunflower oil and also
wheat and grain what gets produced here
and exported has a direct effect on food
prices around the world
it's one of the main reasons why this
deal was brokered the global need to
bring down soaring food prices that
resulted because of the war Russia
controls access in and out of the Black
Sea which Ukraine needs to ship its
produce to the rest of the world
the deal is set to be renewed every four
months Russia now says it only wants to
renew it for two citing sanctions
affecting its own exports
but Ukraine's Deputy head of
infrastructure who's been part of the
team negotiating the grain deal tells us
such a short-term deal does not offer
stability
which is important to the farmers to see
the forecast how they will export their
products during next marketing gear
because in case the farmers see even
four months of bsgi it is also small
period we asked our partners to make it
minimum one year Farmers have also
complained of Russia delaying checks on
vessels transporting produce which costs
more money
we know Russia wants to only extend for
two months but this is not as it should
be
also the vessels that go to Ukraine are
delayed by Russia in the Bosphorus and
we end up paying for this because the
vessels don't reach us on time currently
the Western border with Poland is
working but we cannot fully sell the
grain that we have by road we need the
Sea The Journey out has begun Russia
holds great leverage in just how far
they will reach such tiny seeds and
Grains with major geopolitical
implications Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
jakivitsky on the outskirts of Kiev